in
ithaca new york ale is going to start
off this hour
hi ale welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call how
are you
better than i deserve what's up uh yeah
so um i've been a listener for a few
years now
i discovered you halfway through
undergrad um
i went the first two years just taking
out loans and i ended up taking out
about
forty five thousand dollars alone um and
then my friends showed your [ __ ]
showed me your show i ended up getting
three jobs paid the rest
in cash grad school way to go
um and my grad school is funded i'm
currently my masters
and i'll be starting my phd next year um
and again
funded don't plan on taking out any
loans wow um
yeah and uh yeah and i also cut up all
my credit cards and
totally on your plan i love it great i'm
honored so
uh so what's your phd in going to be in
um yeah so uh epidemiology oh wow good
for you
very cool cool uh yeah so my question is
um
i recently uh tried to start to get into
investing
which i know isn't exactly following a
plan but
i had a little bit of money in my
savings and so i took about
uh just from saving up from working over
the years and so i took about five
thousand dollars last year
and invested it and now i currently have
about
uh 50 000 and so i was wondering
since i will be in my phd for probably
the next five years and i won't have
an income but i also won't be expected
to pay off my loans
should i save that money as
a way to get through the next five years
or should i just go ahead and take that
and pay off my loans
well there's not a bad answer here
everything's going in the right
direction
so uh it's just a matter of what is the
most efficient so
for me job one is for a guy as smart as
you
to complete all of these fields of study
the masters the phd and everything 100
debt-free how sure
are we that we can do that if we use
this money
to pay off the loans in other words that
jeopardizes that goal
if i thought that if i thought this
money might be needed
that there was a 10 chance that the way
you're getting a free phd might fall
through and you might need this money to
complete a debt-free
field of study then i would use the
money on that before i would use it to
reduce your loans while you're in school
job one is graduate debt free no matter
what happens
yeah so who's paying for the phd in the
master's how are you getting all that
done
um it's uh the programs that i'm in
are fully funded for the students
through the school
scholarships fellowship what is this uh
yes
i guess it's through teaching you have
to uh
you have to take part as teaching okay
so if they lost their funding for that
or you lost your teaching position you'd
have to pay for your
your study right correct if we were
going to put a probability on that is it
10
that that could happen two percent that
could happen 25 percent that could
happen
uh yeah i guess i'd have to put it below
five percent
okay then you feel pretty safe about
using this money to pay off your debt
now right
well that's you know that's what i'm
unsure about i don't know if i should
well the point the point is the only way
you would pay off this debt with this
money
is if you know that you know that you
know you're not going to need it to
finish school debt free because job
rule one is get out of the school debt
free then we can address the debts
so if it all plays out the day you
graduate debt-free
or the day you graduate without adding
without having any needy
need of this money the 50 000 would have
grown some more but
when you graduate you take that 50 000
pay off the 45 or you do it today
but if something hiccups you got to find
another way to finish school debt free
gotcha so your choice either one of
those fine but you you can probably
judge that
those probabilities better than i can
from where you're sitting because you're
in the middle of those programs those
institutions you know how solid they are
or they aren't the funding behind them
and the fellowships and whatever it is
you've gotten tied into there so
that's excellent you've done a wonderful
job
very very smart and turning five grand
into 50 grand ain't bad either dude
well done